Alex Rosenberg I started out as
the philosophy um I was cured of the
mistake by David Hume but it was too
late to go back into physics and I ended
up working in the foster economics for a
long time buddy colonists were never
interested what in what anybody had to
say about the problems in their own
discipline so I moved through the
philosophy of biology long ago and I'm
mainly hoping to be able to keep my
mouth shut and listen to at this meeting
because the thing that I could change my
mind about is fairly radical um my own
view is that naturalism is really deeply
incompatible with what Wilfrid Sellars
called the manifest image and I'm sure
that philosophers around this table will
help non philosophers understand what is
meant by the manifest image and of
course there are people around this
table who insist that it is compatible
with large chunks of the manifest image
and if they could change my mind
dan I would be very happy well can you
just give us the one yeah please so the
manifest image is a intelligent
sophisticated well informed version of
common sense of view about the furniture
of reality that reflects what most
people believe it is without being
supernatural except fair down although
good and and I've written a book called
the atheist guide to reality not my
title my title was reality the rough
guide but unfortunately my agent told me
that the rough guide was a term that had
already been copyrighted by somebody
else and in this book I have argued in a
sustained way that naturalism commits us
to reject almost all of the manifest
image and that's why I would like to
have my mind changed
you